en una victoria histórica el partido
liberaldemócrata ganó el viernes un
escaño parlamentario en las elecciones
parciales del norte shop sigue asentando
el golpe en un bastión conservador que
se mantuvo durante casi 200 años la
nueva diputada helen morgan se impuso
con un 34% diferencia sobre su ponente
teoría esta noche los habitantes del
norte de churchill han hablado en nombre
del pueblo británico han dicho alto y
claro boris johnson se acabó la fiesta
su gobierno basado en mentiras y
fanfarronadas tendrá que rendir cuentas
será examinado será cuestionado y puede
y será derrotado es la segunda pérdida
de un escaño tory a manos del partido
liberaldemócrata desde julio y los
conservadores dicen que reflexionarán
sobre ello llevamos 11 años de gobierno
conservador nuestras elecciones nunca
son algo fácil pero por supuesto tenemos
que reflexionar sobre el resultado y
estoy seguro de que como partido lo
haremos
la derrota culmina una semana de reveses
para oris johnson a principios de esta
semana el primer ministro sufrió la
mayor rebelión de su mandato desde que
empezó a ejercer su cargo cuando casi
100 miembros de su propio partido
votaron en contra de las nuevas
restricciones para el coronavirus que él
consideraba necesarias las medidas
finalmente se aprobaron solo gracias al
apoyo del opositor partido laborista lo
que abrió la pregunta de si johnson
había perdido el control de los
conservadores el líder británico también
está en la mira por una costosa reforma
de su residencia en downing street y por
las supuestas fiestas navideñas del
gobierno mientras se decreta una
estricta cuarentena a nivel nacional en
2020 también se ha enfrentado a críticas
por su gestión de la pandemia ya que el
reino unido- lucha actualmente contra
una ola de la variante omicron y tiene
una de las mayores cifras de muertos en
todo el mundo